الدول الفقيره تدفع فاتوره باهظه لارتفاع
اسعار الفائده والتضخم على شكل ازمات
متفاقمه ابرزها طوفان اقتصادي يغرقها
بالديون مقال تحليلي في صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز اشار الى ملامح الازمه التي ستعصف
باقتصاد الدول الناميه التي ستعاني
الامرين اقتصاد مترهل في اساسه يضاف اليه
عبء سداد الديون والتخلف عن دفعها ووافق
بيانات نوراك تايمز تدين هذه الدول
الفقيره بما يصل الى 200 مليار دولار
للدول الغنيه وبنوك التنميه المتعدده
الاطراف والدائنين من القطاع الخاص
تداعيات ازمات عالميه تنكب متواليا على
رؤوس تلك الدول الفقيره بدات بجائزه
كورونا واغلاقاتها صارمه وحرب روسيا في
اوكرانيا منذ تسعه اشهر وبحسب الصحيفه لن
تحدث ازمه يا عالميه لكن التخلف عن السداد
يمكن ان يجعل من الصعب على دول مثل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه التصدير
البضائع الى دول المثقله بالديون مما يؤدي
الى زياده التابات والاقتصاد العالمي
وربما يؤدي الى انتشار الجوع والاضطرابات
الاجتماعيه في بعض تلك الدول حيث توقع
البنك الدولي هذا العام ان حوالي 12 دوله
قد تواجهوا تخلفا عن السداد في العام
المقبل وقدر صندوق صندوق النقد الدولي ان
60% من البلدان الناميه منخفضه الدخل كانت
في ضائقه ديون او معرضه لخطر كبير من
ضمنهم سيرلانكا التي اقتربت من التخلف عن
السداد هذا العامه والتره مصرفها المركزي
الى ترتيب اتفاقيه مقايده لدفع ثمن النفط
الايراني باوراق الشاي حتى الاسواق
الناشئه في تشاد وساميه وغانا تكافح عليه
تطوير خطه لتسريع لتخفيف الديون التي تهدد
اقتصاده هذه بالوايلات وكان محللون
انتقدوا خلال الاجتماعات السنويه لصندوق
النقد الدولي والبنك الدولي في واشنطن
خلال اكتوبر الماضي بطء وتيره اعاده هيكله
الديون ودعوا الى اتخاذ اجراءات منسقه بين
الدائنين والمقترضين لايجاد حلول قبل فوات
الاوان وما تزال الصين التي اصبحت واحده
من اكبر الدائنين في العالم تشكل وعقبه
امام جهود الاغاثه وقد اتهمها خبراء
التنميه بوضع مصائد ديون البلدان الناميه
من خلال برنامج اقراض يزيد عن 500 مليار
وصفه محللون بالخطه المفترسه
[موسيقى]